تشير أبحاث [موسيقى]
إلى
أن الكافيين يمكن أن يقدم مجموعة من الفوائد الصحية المحتملة
، بما في ذلك تحسين الذاكرة
وتحسين الأداء الرياضي ،
ومزايا صحة الكبد
، والحماية المحتملة
من مرض باركنسون.
قد تقلل أكواب القهوة يوميًا
من خطر الموت المبكر ،
وقد ثبت أيضًا أن القهوة تقلل من
مخاطر الإصابة بأمراض مثل مرض السكري من النوع 2
وسرطان القولون والمستقيم والزهايمر وسرطان الجلد ،
بالطبع ، من المهم التحضير إذا كنت
تحب كوبك مع الحليب ،
فاختر قليل الدسم على الكريمة وتجنب
السكر
يختلف تحمل الجميع ، ولكن
بشكل عام ، يمكن للبالغين الأصحاء أن يستهلكوا بأمان
ما يصل إلى 400 ملليجرام من الكافيين يوميًا
أي حوالي
أربعة أكواب من القهوة بثمانية أوقيات ، ومع ذلك قد ترغب
الأمهات المنتظرات وأولئك الذين يعانون من
أمراض القلب في التخلي عن
كوب القهوة.